Speaker 1: All right. Let's talk about
religious vaccine exemptions you hear. So often
we allow religious exemptions or I should
be allowed to get a religious exemption. And
then that brings us to the question of are there
religions that ban vaccination? What exactly are
people talking about? What do they mean or do they
just mean? I've decided it's my personal religious
belief now. This is not a debate over the validity
of religious exemptions. We are examining,
are there anti-vaccine religions? It's actually
pretty tough to find. So let's go through a few
of the things we know. A couple of weeks ago,
I said, you know, maybe Jehovah's Witnesses.
But then I heard from a Jehovah's Witness actually
two different Jehovah's Witnesses who said
we got the vaccine. We were told to get to
take this seriously. Nobody said anything
in our churches about not getting vaccinated. So
the Jehovah's Witnesses I've heard from have said,
No, no, no, we got we got vaccinated. I said,
maybe Christian science. But then I heard from
a Christian scientist who said, Actually,
David, it's fine. It's just it's up to each
individual person. But that being said, there are
reports that the Church of Christ, scientist known
as Christian Science, is an anti-vaccine
religious group. So upon further research,
it appears as though it's sort of up
to the local pastor to some degree.
Now, I know that no matter what I say
about this, someone will disagree. But
the best assessment that I have right
now is that with Christian science,
it is not necessarily anti-vaccine at the
top level, but that there are individual
Christian science pastors who are taking positions
against the vaccine. Now, PolitiFact looked at
this and politics. PolitiFact have found a few of
what they identified as anti-vaccine religions,
but the context was that Dr Anthony Fauci had
said there are precious few religions that
actually say you cannot get vaccinated. That
was determined to be mostly true by PolitiFact.
The summary is there are hundreds of religions,
but in one tally about five van ban vaccination,
people must prove their stances based on a
sincerely held religious belief. Employers
must accommodate it, but not if it would impose
an undue burden on operations. And recent Supreme
Court rulings indicate government should seek
alternatives to mandates. So what does PolitiFact
say? PolitiFact says Vanderbilt University Medical
Center's review of immunization and religion
identified a small subset of Christian faiths
that oppose vaccination on theological grounds.
There are five a group that includes the
Dutch Reformed Church Church of the first born
Faith Assembly and End Time Ministries.
This is not comprehensive now, it says.
Many people might instantly think of Christian
scientists. While many Christian scientists rely
on prayer for healing. The Christian Science
Church offered guidance to members on vaccines
in 2019 and said for more than a century, our
denomination has counseled respect for public
health authorities and conscientious obedience to
the laws of the land, including those requiring
vaccination. Church leaders impose no decision
on church members, but they encourage them to
recognize the seriousness of public health. Church
members are free to make their own choices on all
life decisions in obedience to the law, including
whether or not to vaccinate Protestant faiths,
Islam, Roman and Orthodox Catholicism, Judaism,
Hinduism, Jainism, Islam, Buddhism, Jehovah's
Witnesses and more have no prohibition against
vaccination. So what is the bottom line on this
entire religious exemption thing? The bottom line
is there are very few actual from the top vaccine
prohibitions. There are anecdotally individual
pastors who will rant and rave in churches and
say, We're not bringing the vaccine here, it's
the mark of the Beast, this type of thing. So
when we've seen that, it's typically typically a
random individual evangelical pastor in, you know,
Georgia or Ohio or whatever who is saying, don't
get it, it's bad, bad, bad. And, by the way,
vote for Trump. But that is an individual pastor.
It's not actually from scripture. So I think the
takeaway here is we're not even getting into the
debate over the validity of religious exemptions.
California has made it very difficult to
even get one. But what we are pointing out is
when someone says it's against my religion, we
should ask more questions and say, OK, well,
what is your religion? What is the scripture that
says it's against your religion now? In a purely
empirical standpoint, it really doesn't make a
difference, whether it's in scripture or not or
whether it's a pastor saying it or not, like
what I mean by that is scriptures held up as
supposed holy texts are just that supposed holy
texts. Only if you believe that religion, it's
sort of like trying to impose what the Bible says
on someone who doesn't believe in the Bible. It's
sort of like, Well, I don't I don't care what the
Bible says, because it doesn't. It doesn't apply
to me. I don't care about that. And in the same
way, it's not really that different from a random
random pastor saying, We're not getting vaccinated
here. Don't get vaccinated. The vaccine is bad
from a validity standpoint, but I think the main
takeaway is a lot of the people claiming religious
exemptions. They're not really based in anything
other than maybe a ranting pastor at their church.
So that's what it is very tough to find actual
religious opposition to vaccination. Take it for
what it is. And if you have anything anecdotal
to share about this, about your church or your
community or whatever, find me on Twitter at
the Packman. I would love to hear from you about
it. I don't know that I've mentioned before that
our program does depend on the support of viewers
and listeners to the podcast, people who watch
clips on YouTube or listen to us on the radio,
watch on free speech TV or one of our various
television affiliates. And the best way to support
our program is to sign up at join Packman dot com.
We have great perks. We recently did one of our
viewer town halls where our members get priority,
and speaking to me, we do an extra show every day
for our members and so many other great things.
You can sign up today at join Packman dot com.